islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorize the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah i wanted to share this hadith
that i came across uh i have a book
which is called the signs of the day of
um judgment
the signs of the hour
and one of the things that i came across
brother and sisters is the process of
them and something which we come to see
today
and this is one of the evidences of
islam and the prophet sallam's character
because the things that he mentioned and
prophesied specifically not general or
vague you know or ambiguous it was very
specific to the things that he
prophesized and this is
it cannot be from other than but from
god almighty and this is one of our
evidences to islam being the truth
because if he's the prophet of god
almighty he can prophesy these things
how else could he even know it known it
and there are not tense there are
hundreds of prophecies that we have come
to see one by one
this is one of those the prophet peace
be upon him said
narrated that the message of allah said
the hour would not begin
until tribulations appear fitna there is
a great great deal of lying
listen carefully and the markets will
come close together
and the markets will come close together
brothers and sisters this is the area
that we're living in like no other time
that we have seen
that
amazon ebay
alibaba
you name it
all of them and many many others where
markets
have from all around the world even like
you can mention like you know
supermarkets etc where food from all
over the world
like literally all over the world is in
one place it's at the tip of your finger
if i want to order something from
america yeah or somewhere else it's at
the tip of my finger literally i can go
and order in seconds and it's here
within a matter of days
how did the prophet peace be upon him
make such bold claims because if these
claims were not to come true it ruins
his whole
foundations of islam being true the same
goes with the quran the quranic
prophecies
so this shows us and directs us to no
other place
and this is one of the reasons i
accepted islam one of the reasons
how did the prophet peace be upon him no
this is something that i want to leave
you guys with promises i don't want to
leave this and drag it too much long but
i'm going to be trying to collect these
prophecies and share them with you one
by one because i found them absolutely
profound and amazing how the prophet
peace be upon him is not vague but very
very specific in detail
especially you know when he said about
the barefooted bedouins
he could have said your nation's going
to come and build tall buildings why
barefooted bedouins barefooted and
bedouins why
tall buildings barefooted bedouins and
tall buildings that's so specific
and if his message was not from allah he
would have never made vague statements
of that or he would have limited his
prophecies but his prophecies were so
many
so many to mention so brothers and
sisters in sha allah hope he benefited
from that inshallah and see that the
message of allah is true his messenger
is a true messenger and the quran is his
kitab is this kalam
it's his speech brothers and sisters
till next time inshallah i hope you
enjoyed this video inshallah if there is
any other prophets that you want to
mention in the bottom inshallah let me
know and i can do a video about it till
next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh
where is it where where is it
i'm going to the masjid in time to pray
tomorrow it's a beautiful day
where is the masjid where is the masjid
where's the masjid
where is the save iman norway masjid i
can't see it where is it
relax relax alhamdulillah we've
purchased this huge
2700 square meters building with this
huge seven and a half thousand square
meters of land and insha'allah with your
help we are going to convert this huge
property into the most epic islamic
center in the whole country of norway
click the button to donate whatever you
can
[Music]